[Music]
thank you
thank you for joining us on spectator TV
Douglas
um you're out in the magazine this week
about your time touring American
universities with the common sense group
um can you tell us about the tour and
how it's gone
yes I'm always very eager to engage in
um discussion dialogue debate and much
more
um and uh especially with students
because in America as in as in Britain
there is an enormous camber cultural
movement going on at the moment in our
universities and I think it doesn't get
itself counted enough
so I've been uh day after day going to
different campuses uh speaking of my
other things about about getting uh the
past in some kind of historical context
um in America even more than in Britain
there is this is wild collapse of
knowledge and context about the past uh
people students faculty and others seem
to believe their job is to stand as
judge durian executioner over everyone
who came before them and you write in
particular about Thomas Jefferson now I
think most of us would know Jefferson
one of the founding fathers one of the
first presidents you know quite a noble
figure you say these days it's almost
like a Mark of Cain to be associated
with him can you can you tell us a bit
about that and why what's going on there
yes that's right I mean one of the
fascinating things in American Life in
recent years as in British life has been
the way in which all of the central
Heroes have been sort of pulled down one
by one in Britain we've seen this in
recent years with the constant attacks
on Winston Churchill and his memory uh
Lord Nelson Francis Drake it doesn't
matter who you who you find are the
heroes that many of us grew up with all
them are looked at in the same
remorseless light it's even worse in
America uh
um because a new generation of students
and and rather poorly qualified
professors have made Amazing Discoveries
such as the fact that the founding
fathers uh lived in a time in which
slavery was commonplace
um Thomas Jefferson has come in for a
particular oblique in recent years uh
largely because of of a story that has
emerged since the 1990s which claims not
only that he was a slave owner but a
slave Raper and that one of the slaves
inherited in particular
um was was the father of his children in
actual fact as I mentioned in my piece
and as I've been mentioning in
speeches in the past weeks the DNA
evidence on This is highly inconclusive
there is a def a Jefferson a gene within
the DNA of Sally Hemmings the the slaves
uh descendants but it's by no means Kurt
this is from Thomas Jefferson's much
more likely it is one uh one of a couple
of Nair do well relatives known to go to
the slave quarters why does this matter
um I mean it it it it wouldn't or
shouldn't wipe out in any case all of
his other achievements Declaration of
Independence the Virginia statute on
religious liberty and much more but
um but today
um of course it means that the fact that
that not in the country but institutions
like the University of Virginia founded
by Thomas Jefferson uh feel the need to
sort of uh um somehow dispense with
their past or or deal with their pastors
as racist institutions and as
institutions founded also by a rapist
which is I mean a hundred years ago if
you'd have said that Thomas Jefferson
was a rapist uh you would have found
people quite angry that you'd made such
a claim uh today as I found
um in recent uh recent uh speeches uh
quite a lot of you were quite angry if
you say you think Thomas Jefferson was
not a rapist
um so um a lot has changed and it's
changed very fast and with an awful lot
of ignorance do you get a sense I mean
so going around these campuses that this
is a view held by the majority of
students is there a bit of a fight back
going on do you think to sort of you
know view history in a more reasonable
way
yeah I mean the dimmer students have
fallen for the work stuff I mean there's
no doubt about that
um the ones who just you know heard like
go along with um with with you know the
other the other sheep on this sort of
thing
um uh the the cleverer students uh in my
experience everywhere uh finding their
way through this I mean they recognize
that you know sort of uh unattractive
and unsustainable to Simply you know
find guilty everyone who died before you
were born and and it's also not very
interesting I mean there's so much of
interest in the life of somebody like
Thomas Jefferson as with all the
founding fathers who are remarkable
figures uh there's so much that's
interesting about them there's just
nothing very interesting about being a
retributive uh prigish ill-informed uh
individual who just wants to find
everyone guilty of of living in you know
the 18th century tree for instance you
know I mean I mean I mean you know lo
and behold who'd have guessed John that
uh that that people who lived before we
were born had different attitudes to us
on a range of things doubting those
people who come after us we'll have
different attitudes themselves heaven
forbid yes um and you sort of allude to
you as well in your piece about the fact
there's been this big Reckoning over
even the date that America was founded
um I think you're referring to the 69
projects can you tell us a bit about
that and how this kind of influenced
things as well
yeah there's a there's a very very
ill-educated ill-informed uh woman
called Nicole Hannah Jones Nicole Hannah
Jones is not a historian she's not
anything as far as I want to see except
that the the New York Times in the
infinite wisdom decided to make her the
sort of chair of this project that
decided in its own words to reframe the
American founding and to reframe it to
1619 which was the date when when today
is the first brought on to the American
continent
um this is of course a completely um a
malevolent rewriting of American History
it's an attempt not to just say slavery
happened which it did as it did in every
civilization around the world but that
slavery is the sole lens to look at
America through it's like saying that
racism or colonialism which also existed
in in our past as they did in all past
are the only way to look at our past and
of course as I say there's an entirely
malevolent rewriting it's if you did
this to Brazil Zeal is perfectly
possible you could do it to Brazil you
could do it to Nigeria
um I mean the most odious slaving was
continuing in Nigeria among Nigeria you
know into the 20th century uh Britain
and others fought about this but if you
said you know Nigeria is just this
country with its original sin and
there's nothing good to be said about it
most Nigerians were quite rightly you
know chase you out of town and and say
this isn't fair but Nicola Hannah Jones
and others have made this claim about
America they have fundamentally altered
the debate in America not because of the
strength of their argument they never
defend their arguments because they
don't have arguments they just have
assertions and Nicole Hannah Jones and
others will not debate their assertions
in public they simply say they simply
throw out bombs and then say I refuse
the platform anyone who disagrees with
me that's because their ideas their
claims don't stand up to even the
slightest scrutiny but nevertheless it's
caused that another um a series of
serious frictions in America and as I
mentioned in my piece there's a sort of
counter factual here which is not just
the counter factor of the 1619 project
but if we'd have gone back a couple of
decades and said you know what are we
going to spend our time debating in the
world's most advanced democracies in
Britain and America
um you know we might have thought 20
years ago well gosh it was since we've
got the internet and access to all this
knowledge and the opportunity to
exchange ideas we might solve all sorts
of things instead you know we're
discussing things like what's a woman
and uh when was America founded so
actually we've become stupider and um I
for at any rate I had any rate blame
people like Hannah Jones and her fellow
fabulous and and I wish they wouldn't
hold everyone back I mean Douglas you
mentioned there that we thought we'd use
the internet for great things I mean how
much do you think the internet can be
blamed for this I mean in terms of
elevating quite shrill or unpleasant
voices that probably would have been
ignored in the past
well as I mentioned in the piece you
know there's a quote that Henry
Kissinger gave to The Spectator nine
years ago or so he said everyone's got
this access to this knowledge but
where's the wisdom uh he referred to
Lord Salisbury and uh the way he acted
whilst he was prime minister of Britain
um you have to have time to acquire
wisdom if you just got constant access
to knowledge you might well miss the
wisdom uh we live in a time when any
student can open their iPad and you know
Google something and say ah I see uh
that this fact is there but but the
context of things the wisdom of things
is getting entirely lost in this
unbelievable febrile certainty which is
fueled by very ignorant people with tiny
amounts of information at their disposal
I don't hop on about her because she's
not a very interesting figure
um but Nicole Hannah Jones and Her
colleagues at the 1619 project uh talk
about the um American founding and don't
seem to think that the Declaration of
Independence is in any way a suggestive
or useful or important document
something which I I demure from yes and
I imagine Jefferson would be turning in
his grave as well a bit if he said that
his his declaration didn't matter
brilliant and thank you very much
Douglas
it's great pleasure
[Music]